10 GAMES, BUT HE'S
GOING TO PLAY THAT ONE AWAY
FROM THE NET.
HOW DROPS
UP IN THE LINEUP HERE BECAUSE T
TO CR
MISSING THE SECOND GAME ON THE
COVID PROTOCOL LIST, HE PUTS IT
BACK, THERE'S IT DOWN.AND IN.
PIETRANGELO SETTING UP 499
GETS BACK ON THE NEAR BOARDS,
T
SERGACHEV, McDONOUGH AND UP THE
CENTER.
THTHERE'S A SIDE
POST.
>> Dave: WOULD ONLY HAS ONE
GOAL IN HIS
HOPS OVER THE STICK OF HEDMAN A
BACK WITH A DEFENSIVELY.
BACK THE WAY IT COMES, THERE'S
FROM THE OUTSIDE.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE MIDDLEL
PRESSURED BACK BY OF
>> Dave: JOHN COOPER WITH HIS
OFFENSIVE ZONE LAST COUPLE
YEARS, THE REASON THEY WON TWO
STRAIGHT D
UP WITH HEDMAN.
AND HEDMAN GAVE
SIDE, IN THERE, OPEN, LATE STAG
>> THIS WAS LAUGHTER ] HERE WE
TONIGHT'S TAKES THE SHOT
OVER THE RIGHT PAD OF THE
STOPPED FOURTH ROUND.
>> Brian: MARCHEPADDLE OF THE
STICK DOWN.
HE IS PATIENT. GOALTENDER'S
EYE, TO GO.
>> Dave: VASILEVSKIY WITH A
CHANCE TO WIN IT AGAINST T MY G
UNDER PRESSURE A LITTLE BIT THE
PERFECT SHOT RIGHT ON ROUND SHO
THIS IS ROUND NUMBER SEVEN
GOININU'VE GOT A
LOT OF SHOOTERS WHEN MAMA